for most people in Poland the world has
long ended here at the border to Belarus
but since June foreign tourists have
been able to visit Belarus for up to
three days without a visa there's been a
steady stream of people coming to check
it out
walkers cyclists and even the border
police themselves now that it's so easy
why miss out my passage through Polish
customs is Swift and suddenly I find
myself outside the EU you don't need a
visa for Belarus but you do have to
register in advance through a travel
agency and then there are of course the
obligatory forms to fill out on the
Belarusian side our shuttle bus awaits
bit of a disappointment for the walkers
you are allowed to go on foot but only
if you stick to the road your gig Neuse
Levin York works as a tour operator and
is constantly traveling around Belarus
he knows how to stick to the rules and
still have a good time it's a bit
restrictive you can't just go walking
around the forest because it's a
national park but that doesn't bother
most tourists they still get to see
enough if they stick to the rules so far
there haven't been any disputes with
soldiers or border police even in
Belarus times have changed what makes
this region so fascinating is the huge
forest that crosses the entire border
region although we don't get to see much
of it on the trip but 20 kilometers from
the border we arrive at a kind of
tourist centre
but it turns out it's pretty empty our
first stop the currency exchange office
200 thousand for just over 10 euros then
it's off to a restaurant local
businesses here are hoping to attract
lots of holes
the first challenge though is trying to
read the menu it's raining but finally
I'm allowed to go off exploring this
part of the forest is open to foreigners
like me thanks to the director of the
National Park or rather his friendship
with President Alexander Lukashenko
there's plenty to see like this ancient
oak tree it's 600 years old it's
survived it's ours Kings the Communist
general secretaries it's belonged to
Russia Poland Lithuania and it's still
standing
as I make my way back to the border I
meet some polish day visitors who are
heading home so how was the day out in
Belarus absolutely positive it's a
beautiful area everything's well
organized good routes for cyclists I'm
surprised
so we had some problems at the border we
didn't take out any insurance we didn't
know we needed to first we had to go
back and sort that out we haven't had
much time today but they're all planning
to return and I can see why before it
was very difficult to come here now with
the visa restrictions lifted
it's rather enticing